Kourtney Kardashian is all smiles
hanging with her rumored beau the Subodh
big facts the 39 year old TV personality
was spotted leaving an off-white event
at Gagosian Gallery in Beverly Hills on
Wednesday as she left the fashion event
court kay was seen spending time with a
20 year old grown his star and
eyewitness says the pair looked happy
together as they headed to their ride we
really had the best time ever
the duo sported fashion-forward looks
court wearing a see-through tank black
bra and bold snakeskin print pants while
Luca looked laid-back in a black graphic
print hoodie and matching sneakers but
last month the source told ET the dating
rumors between Kourtney and Luca are
totally bogus adding quote Courtney is
100% not dating Luca they have some
friends in common and have become
friends but it's nothing more than that
I don't really have all the details I'm
just meeting wives the friendly duo
first sparked romance rumors after
showing PDA during a night out in
Chicago then they were seen out in LA
earlier this month Kourtney and Luca
also hung out with kendall Jenner and
rumored boyfriend and more Hadid I can't
even live my life I can't even go
anywhere
our et source assures us the mom of
three is still on the market quote
Kourtney is very happily single she is
not dating anyone at the moment
her focus as always continues to be her
children and her family over it
you